[Music]
you know i think i have to start with uh
some congratulations that are in order
i'm hearing that you just signed with
gatorade i mean how does it feel to just
hear that
it's crazy it's surreal i'm super
excited
gatorade is like the sports leader in
fueling and they have
plenty of household names so to be part
of that family is crazy
yeah because i would assume i mean you
grew up drinking gatorade all the time
and now you're totally a part of the
family i mean did little paige
everything hey i'm gonna partner with
these people one day absolutely not i
was just thinking man i need a gatorade
every time i play basketball every time
at the park every time after workout
that was my drink but i never thought i
would be a part of that
can we both agree that like glacier
freeze is the best flavor followed by
cool blue
but glacier
glacier cherry
that's
glacier freeze is good glacier cherry is
my favorite for sure well now it's time
to see if you're good at heads up okay
do you want to do
movies tv basketball or superstars
basketball
uh damien lillard's team
trailblazers yep
this he played with kobe um he is very
close with vanessa
uh yes
oh this is a movie about a
non-black dude who can play basketball
like me and kendra yes
um this is um pistol blank he has like
videos
yeah but yes pistol p that's it yeah but
his last name pete maravich yes okay
toronto raptor great dunker
vince carter yes
this is when you shoot the ball and it
goes like right in
it's a no it's a phrase for that it's
like
it's like okay what is the white thing
called around the hoop
the no nothing but no yes yes yes yes
that was good okay we were good we were
good
you want women's sports to be recognized
and elevated in a very authentic way do
you truly feel that that shift is
happening uh for women's sports
i do i think i mean it's not going to be
something that happens overnight and
over a small period of time it's going
to be something that's going to be
worked on for a long time but i think
it's important for people like me who
have huge media platforms and a huge way
to do it i think it's important that we
put that at the forefront and that's
been
huge in every one of my deals every one
of my partnerships and i think i mean i
can see the changes there's a long way
to go obviously but little steps in
progress are important you have been an
advocate for all groups of people most
notably women and black women
at what point would you say that that
became a major priority for you
i think in high school i'm growing up
right right outside of minneapolis i saw
a lot of police brutality in the city
and in my state and i saw
the way it impacted
our communities and our culture just in
the state of minnesota so i mean that
was something that i wanted to change
and i just
have a positive voice in i mean i went
to marches i went to a lot of community
driven things
around black lives matter so as i
continued in college
me being a white woman i had a lot of
focus in the media on espn and all of
the sports platforms that exist how was
it finding that voice
i was hard it took some like challenging
conversations because it's not something
that i can speak on from experience
so to speak with other black women and
other black people in different
communities it was challenging to have
those conversations but i think that's a
part of growth and that's a part of
change having hard conversations and
conversations you necessarily don't want
to have
but i think it's very important all
right so these are your custom decks
okay
uh this is a basketball magazine
slam magazine yep
okay slam blink
like in basketball when you hit the ball
yes yes yes
um you won this award
he is a basketball coach
wooden award yes down with it yep
uh yukon player plays for the storm
uh rana shirt super yup
yup brandon
uh this uh player plays for the nets i
think growing up he was your favorite
player kyrie yes you're much better than
people that we have on here a lot of
people aren't very good at that game i
must say
that's pretty cool
whenever i bring you up to people they
will say something to the effect of i've
never seen a player like paige
when you hear people say that what do
you think they mean by that
i think the first thing that comes to
mind is probably my confidence in my
sort of aura on the court people use the
word swag
i would say that's accurate description
but
i think it's just
i think
i don't know it's i think there's a lot
of things that go into that i think my
passing ability is one of them i take
pride in my the way i pass my vision
and then just my ability to do multiple
things
whether it be score defend
pass is the my favorite but i think
first probably comes like the aura
yeah i mean it's so nice hearing like a
basketball player say they enjoy passing
everybody wants to shoot yeah
how did you learn to love passing the
ball
i think it was just a young age i think
a lot of it is the god-given talent
i mean you can practice shooting can do
ball handling but the vision and the way
you see the court
it's hard to practice that
um so when i like i found out i had that
gift the way i see things sort of before
they happen and i just love doing it
everybody loves scoring everybody can
score but passing is probably definitely
my favorite thing
uh when you get fouled you see one of
these
free throws yeah
where i went to high school
i just read this last night it's in
minnesota hopkins yes
[Applause]
where i go to college
uk
yes
um it's like
the best chicken spot closed on sundays
not the best chick-fil-a and it is the
best
um
criminal minds what are they
like the people
uh agents yeah in in what department
cia fbi fbi
fbi
uh the partnership the drink i just
signed with gatorade yeah
uh point guard for the
storm
sue bird yep
uh it's when i'm from
where who's from
time's up it was minnesota
oh
dang a glitch okay we did well you know
what you're pretty good a heads up i'll
give you that
i want to talk about expectations okay
which one is heavier the expectations
that you had coming into uconn as a
freshman
or the expectations that you have to
follow up an amazing freshman year with
a better sophomore year
i think now
that i've shown people sort of what i'm
capable of and when you're a freshman
everybody be like oh she's just a
freshman but now that i'm a sophomore
i think things are sort of ramped up and
last year we didn't win a national
championship and i also think that's a
huge expectation when people and kids
decide to go to uconn that if you go to
uconn you gotta win a national
championship just because that's what
the program is all about so
i think the
expectations are
heaviest most now do you think that your
coach gina oriama is misunderstood by
the public in some ways
yeah coach's coach i mean
you got to know him you got to know his
sense of humor his personality
a lot of people judge the way like his
strictness the way he coaches players
with stuff he says but he has such a
great heart he's such a great human and
honestly he gets on us and he's hard on
us because he wants to see us when he
wants to see us succeed he doesn't want
us to look bad in the media
and on the court just because he knows
how people portray uconn and portray him
but
i mean he wants the best for us and
whether it be yelling at us making fun
of us
it's all a part of the way he loves us
so
yeah his press conferences always have
some sound bite that everyone is
discussing
all right tell me biggest thing that you
need to work on the rest of the season
the biggest thing i need to work on
definitely probably my leadership my
ability to use my voice
and just
sort of taking ownership of the team and
leading them i see things before they
happen so being able to share that with
my teammates to make it easier for
them and me and just
helping our coaches coach i think is
huge for us
okay nice well paige you've signed this
big great deal uh with gatorade you're
talented you're a leader you're breaking
barriers and you're only 20 years old so
with all that said i mean what do you
want a 25 year old page to be doing
continuing to
sort of lead change in not only the
women's game but in sports in general
um just continue to be the positive
light continue to be a great role model
and obviously keep working hard so i can
keep succeeding on the court and i hope
to win three national championships by
that time and then
hopefully going to the league so
huge things huge things
amazing well we will all be watching
every single step of the way congrats on
everything you're doing huge congrats on
gatorade i'm rooting for you and i wish
you the best of luck rest of the season
and beyond thank you so much
thank you for your time